Oh top of me Oh give it up for Lisa
Silverstone y'all oh my gosh we're
totally buggin Alicia Silverstone
surprised fans over the weekend at a
clueless screening and the Hollywood
Forever Cemetery and only et caught up
with the star to share a special
flashback surprise we ET were on set
when you are filming clueless this was
our very first interview with you when
you were 18 markers back row ok share
which is my character is the most
perfectly dressed classy but the highest
of fashion and I remember a funny story
was that I you know at that time in my
life I wore jeans and a green t-shirt
every single day and that was it I just
didn't get fashion at all I was kind of
a tomboy and I just wasn't into it so
when we had the fittings yeah I was just
like what is going on why am I in these
fittings for so long and I just didn't
get it until I saw the movie and then I
was oh I get it the costumes are the
star of the movie what the hell is that
a dress says who
Calvin Klein I took so much of the
clothes and I'm really sad if I don't
have any of them anymore it's like a
ding dong I got home with all the
clothes and I was like how am I gonna
wear these Mary Jane's now out and so I
just gave a lot of it away and I don't
have any of it yeah but I had a lot of
it back on set young Alicia also
admitted to et that she used real-life
mean girls as the inspiration to get
into the character of Cher because I
grew up I did not like these kind of
girls I would I could not stand them
it's so hard for me to even pick up like
to get into this character I grew up
with a nice area and all these girls had
everything I knew all those kind of
girls one in particular but one thing
they don't have which cher does is not
solid 100% pure good heart and like
happiness you've known girls like cher
who was that one girl in particular
I don't even know I think I know I was
talking about but we're really good
friends now so it's really funny now you
brought your son with you tonight is
this the first time you seen the movie
yes and he might get bored but whatever
we'll see I sense girls talking about
boys and clothes and things names like
that sounds cool
[Music]
you